[Music]
the entertainment capital getting yet
another major sporting event this is
huge formula one racing returning to las
vegas after almost four decades so it's
set to happen not until november of next
year right in the heart of the las vegas
strip as joe muller shows us this means
a lot for our city
[Music]
this will be one huge event for las
vegas to give you some perspective 65
thousand people can fit in a legion
stadium 170 000 people are expected to
be here to watch these race cars speed
down one of the most iconic streets in
the world
formula one is coming to las vegas this
is video from the grand prix in austin
texas an event that attracted tens of
thousands john yaskowitz drove hundreds
of miles for that race i think it's
growing every year and for us it's an
event during the season races happen all
over the world in the u.s it is austin
miami and now las vegas race cars will
be going 200 miles per hour on a 3.8
mile track on and around the strip there
will be 50 laps clark county estimates
170 000 people are expected to be here
for the race plus tens of millions
around the world will watch that's going
to be something they haven't seen before
wednesday it was made official that the
race will happen on a saturday in
november 2023. now we've got one of the
largest events in the world while racing
isn't new to las vegas those in the
racing industry know what this means
jeff molly is the vice president of
communications for the las vegas motor
speedway formula one certainly has an
incredible international following i
mean they race all over the world it's
been nearly 40 years since las vegas
hosted a f-1 race like this i hear the
race is going to be at night and so to
see anything under the lights you know
anytime you can do something under the
lights on the las vegas strip it really
resonates around the world motley says
this means a lot for our city there's
going to be a huge economic impact and
that's going to be the hotels that's
going to be the restaurants that's going
to be rental cars airport landing fees
everything that goes into that county
officials say they expect 400 000 hotel
room nights to be booked for this event
they expect the race to bring in 700
million dollars to our local economy
reporting on the strip joe molder live
local now